redondo beach and other coastal areas of
southern california are bracing for
record crowds this labor day weekend
tens of thousands of people will try to
get relief from a heat wave that is
gripping the state and much of the west
a few weeks ago death valley national
park in california hit 130 degrees
it is believed to be the highest
temperature ever recorded on planet
earth
for many across the country it was a
scorching summer but not just in the
west
in fact the place warming faster than
anywhere else might surprise you
recently we paid a visit to get the
facts and maybe a peek
into our future it has become america's
newest
hotspot in more ways than one as
families have flocked to maine
for summer road trips during the
pandemic something else is on the rise
as well
[Applause]
water temperatures in the gulf of maine
stretching from cape cod to nova scotia
are warming faster than anywhere else in
the lower 48.
things are changing and they're changing
fast andrew pershing
is chief scientist at the gulf of maine
research institute
so far they've measured more than 100
heat wave days in gulf of maine waters
this year heatwave is a really new term
in
oceanography and the idea is just like a
heat wave on land we're trying to
capture the idea of conditions that are
abnormally
warm and that are persistent a heat wave
day means the water temperature is at or
above the 90th percentile of the average
temperature going back 30 years
over the next 30 years a new report put
together by 11 democratic senators
says the u.s needs to spend 400 billion
dollars every year to fight
warming waters and the effects of
climate change i think
we're a little bit past just saying you
know climate change is real the arctic
is melting
sheldon whitehouse of rhode island is
one of the report's authors
you have millions of people right now
who are having a tough time putting the
next meal on the table yeah
do you think you can convince them that
trillions extra should be spent
to fight climate change well because
many more trillions will be saved
what do you want people to take away
from this report the biggest thing i
think
is that climate denial and the fight
we're having
over addressing climate change
is truly not a partisan issue
when i got to the senate in 070809 it
was perfectly bipartisan
the report says the goal should be to
create 10 million new jobs in clean
energy manufacturing and development
which they believe could prevent further
changes especially right here
one of the troubling things that we've
started to notice is some big changes at
the base of the food web in the gulf of
maine some really critical
plankton species that are food for lots
of other animals
and we're losing some of our sub-polar
species like cod like northern shrimp
the warming waters have actually
increased the number of lobster
in maine but pershing believes on the
current course
those numbers will eventually plummet we
have done
a projection that looks at how
temperature impacts lobster and our
projection says that if we
get our carbon emissions under control
and stabilize the temperatures then the
gulf of maine holds on to a lobster
fishery
if we blow through those targets and we
end up with a high co2 world
by the end of the century maine won't be
a lobster state anymore
it's hard to imagine maine without
lobster
it definitely is i think it's it's a
really hard thing to get your head
around but that's the challenge that we
all face so you think about other
classic species or trees or
animals that are associated with a place
all of those things are now moving
across the map
as we're warming the planet up you
wouldn't think it right that the
main yeah the gulf of maine would be
warming faster than anywhere else
in the lower 48 but that is what's
happening a hundred heat wave days
just this year in the gulf of maine
waters lobsters in maine
there's more right now because the water
is warmer but the concern is about the
future yeah and there's a lot of people
in maine this summer
man oh man good to see